[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt es
ist schon eine weile her aber ich hatte
euch mal in meinen stories gezeigt wie
ich joghurts helfer wache meine mama hat
die macht es im prinzip schon immer so
also mama macht immer den joghurt selber
sie ist gar keinen gekauften joghurt
weil er am besten schmeckt ich mag aber
auch ganz gerne den sahnejoghurt ist
denn wirklich super gerne aber ich es
auch gerne selbst gemachten joghurt ich
zeige euch heute wie und ihr braucht im
prinzip nur zwei zutaten zum einen ist
es nämlich milch dann nämlich jetzt
einen liter und zwei esslöffel joghurt
entweder nehmen die den sahnejoghurt
roten selbstgemachten joghurt also ich
habe jetzt hier auch bisschen selbst
gemachten joghurt von meiner mama ich
kann aber auch den hier benutzen oder
ihn im dokument das ist aber ein
bisschen schwieriger zu bekommen in
reformhäusern oder auch online ist es zu
kaufen
aber wie gesagt nehmt einfach ein
sahnejoghurt wenn ich's stichfest haben
wollt oder auch ganz einfach einen
anderen joghurt bei naturjoghurt könnte
gerne zwei drei esslöffel mehr benutzen
und ansonsten war es schon was ihr
wissen müsst ist dass die milch
verwendet die ist ganz wichtig entweder
nimmt ihr frische milch vom bauern oder
eben einfach hoch erhitzte milch dies
eben im tetrapack gibt ich habe jetzt
hier auch die tetra pak milch und die
tetra pak mädels die ist ja schon
erwärmt das heißt die ist ja schon ultra
lange haltbar und da gibt es noch diese
frischmilch dies gibt die sieben tage
haltbar und da ist einfach nur wichtig
dass die milch einmal dann praktisch
erwärmt wird auf 95 grad wie etwa fünf
minuten damit einfach alle bakterien
abgetötet werden die eine struktur
verändert sich dann auch das eben der
joghurt gebildet wird aber bei der tetra
pak milch da ist es alles im prinzip
schon erledigt ich werde jetzt gleich
trotzdem erhitzen
das heißt ich habe jetzt hier meine
milch jetzt fehlt hier einfach eure
milch in einem topf und könnt ihr dann
thermometer benutzen oder ihr geht so
ein bisschen nach gefühl ich mache jetzt
tatsächlich mit einem thermometer
ich habe jetzt hier einen topf da kann
ich es rein geben direkt vom kabelloses
thermometer anschließen
es ist einfach mit meiner kochstelle
verbunden aber ansonsten könnt ihr nach
gefühl gehen und das muss bis könnte um
90 grad erhitzt werden
das heißt ist kurz vom kochen also dass
die milch einfach nicht überkocht fünf
minuten erhitzen
wie gesagt bei tetra pak milch ist
eigentlich nicht notwendig macht sie
aber gerne trotzdem ich verbinde es
einfach kurz meinen thermometer dann
muss ich nämlich nichts drauf achten
aber wie gesagt einfach erhitzen bis
kurz vor dem kochen fünf minuten lang
das geht natürlich auch
sich
hier könnte ansonsten auch gerne so ein
manuelles thermometer benutzen das
könnte dann so reinstecken und einfach
auf die temperaturanzeige aber wie
gesagt 95 grad ist gerade so der punkt
an dem die milch eben nicht überkocht
also von daher erkennt man so auch ganz
gut
während die männchen zehn grad noch warm
wird könnt ihr auch schon mal eure
gefäße desinfizieren das heißt einfach
kurz auskochen in heißem wasser im topf
oder kurz im dampfgarer im backofen so
dass er wirklich schön steril sind damit
ihr euch da einfach keine keime und
bakterien reinhold und der joghurt eben
auch schön fest wird das ist wirklich
wichtig bei mir ist jetzt die milch auch
gleich war
ich warte noch kurz 23 minuten und dann
geht es gleich weiter
jetzt kommt der beste papa der joghurt
herstellung nämlich kaymak wenn meine
mutter immer joghurt macht bis heute
nach liebigs diese obere schicht dieser
schicht so weg zum löffel und jetzt muss
die milch wieder herunter kühlen und
zwar auf etwa 50 grad und wenn ihr jetzt
kein thermometer habt wie wahrscheinlich
die meisten von euch dann wartet ihr
einfach jetzt und rührt immer wieder
schön um und meine mutter hat immer
gesagt hände waschen und dann den
kleinen finger nehmen und in die milch
stecken
und wenn die mädels etwas wärmer als
handball ist und einfach so so kurz
kommen verbrennen des kleinen fingers
ist sie so etwa bei 50 grad und dann ist
die temperatur perfekt also darf nicht
so heiß sein weil dann einfach die
joghurt bakterien nicht funktionieren
aber auch nicht zu kalt und gerade so um
50 grad rum vermehren sich die joghurt
kulturen eben am meisten und daher
möchte man auch diese temperatur
erreichen
also warte ich jetzt einfach bis es
schön abkühlt wer sicher gehen will
nimmt wie gesagt wieder ein thermometer
aber es funktioniert auch alles ohne
also joghurt herstellen macht man schon
seit jahrtausenden auch schon immer ohne
werkzeug ohne technik wenn ihr habt
könnt ihr sie nutzen wenn nicht dann
einfach wirklich auf die tipps achten
von meiner mama ich nehme es aber
erstmal den raum haus und es die nämlich
auf
das ist das beste wieso pudding hartmann
manche mögen so manche nicht aber ich
liebe aber es ein bisschen heiß
[Musik]
übrigens habe ich jetzt eine 35
prozentige mitgenommen wenn ihr den
joghurt cremiger haben möchte also so
ein bisschen sauer und voller könnt ihr
gern noch ein becher sahne zufügen
meiner mama macht den joghurt auch immer
gerne aus 3,8 prozent ermittelt
wenn er was sagt ich möchte gar nicht so
viel fett drin haben dann könnte auch
eine 1,5 millionen 15 prozentigem
entnehmen wie gesagt je mehr fett umso
cremiger aber es hat mir das stich
lässigkeit später eigentlich relativ
wenig zu tun
jetzt hat die milch die perfekte
temperatur wie gesagt ihr könnt ihr im
thermometer überprüfen 50 grad oder den
kleinen sauberen gewaschen und finger in
die milch rein halten und diese wirklich
so dass ich so denkt okay mein finger
verbrennt gleich aber ich kann ihn
trotzdem ganz gut drin halten also nicht
so heiß und nicht zu kalt duschen und
dann nehme ich jetzt einfach meine
joghurt kultur also aus meinem joghurt
hier der von der mama das auch recht gut
aber ich glaube ich nehme jetzt doch den
und mit mamas joghurt mache ich dann
einfach später noch mal eine portion
joghurt denn bei uns regelrecht oft und
viel gegessen
also einfach jetzt zwei esslöffel
joghurt reingeben schön verrühren und
bei diesen 50 grad vermehren sich die
joghurt kulturen wie gesagt am besten
und entweder findet ihr jetzt die masse
in einem in ein großes gefäß ein und
habe dann einfach ein joghurt gefäß oder
nehmt viele kleine und ich habe gerne
viele kleine dann können wir jeden tag
so eine neue fraktion nämlich einfach an
löffeln und die kinder essen auch gerne
den joghurt einfach so aus dem glas
jetzt habe ich ja alles schön verrührt
meine sterilisierten gläser aus dem
backofen
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich hier die joghurt
milch eingießen ich nehme jetzt ein paar
im mai station in der türkei wird
joghurt nämlich immer traditionell in so
kleinen schälchen oder in so kleinen
tröpfchen serviert und dann nehme ich
ein paar weckgläser aber ohne gummi also
ich mach dir einfach mit dem deckel dann
zu
[Musik]
ich gebe es hier noch die deckel drauf
einfach locker drauf legen ohne gummi
dazwischen die im schälchen lasse ich
jetzt sogar offen
denn ich bereit in joghurt jetzt im
automaten so bei 50 grad so kann ich
nämlich konstant die temperatur halten
ihr könnt es aber auch natürlich ganz
ohne technik machen und einfach den
joghurt geschlossen in ein schönes
handtuch einwickeln gerne auch noch
unter die bettdecke stecken also hier
ist jetzt einfach nur wichtig dass über
vier bis fünf stunden hinweg der joghurt
einfach schön warm bleibt damit sich die
joghurt kulturen wirklich schön
vermehren aber auch nicht zu heiss das
heißt ihr könnt auch den backofen gerne
vorheizen auf 50 grad dann abschalten
und dann den joghurt hineingeben und ich
probier's jetzt einfach mal einmal mit
deckel einmal ohne
denn im der automaten habe ich noch den
vorteil dass ja auch die feuchtigkeit
entzogen wird und das joghurt sozusagen
auch schon stichfest wird und vor allem
wird dann die flüssigkeit die sich oben
gerne oft absetzt einfach mit weg gesagt
ja es gibt auch joghurt automaten
ich glaube ihr bleiben daheim ja ich
glaube damit kann man dann nur joghurt
machen
ich weiß nicht ich hatte das noch nie ja
meine mama die hat es wie gesagt immer
einfach nur in ein tuch eingewickelt
schön kuschelig und dann den backofen
gestellt und es funktioniert natürlich
auch aber da er immer fragt was kann ich
denn so alles mit dem automaten machen
joghurt könnt ihr zum beispiel auch
machen also hier rein und dann nach der
wärme
kuschel einheit vom joghurt also
wirklich so etwa 45 stunden mindestens
drin lassen gerne auch elf stunden
und danach kommt der joghurt einfach für
etwa zwölf stunden im kühlschrank dann
wird das schön festwirt und kalt wird
und dann könnt ihr ihn messen und
probieren
[Musik]
perfekt jetzt einfach nur noch abwarten
mein joghurt weiß für etwa sechs stunden
im automaten und er ist auch wirklich
schon fertig also wenn er es ohne der
automat und ohne backofen macht einfach
nur in einem handtuch macht dann lasst
den joghurt am besten wirklich elf bis
zwölf stunden einfach schön erstmal warm
und dann kühle sowieso von alleine ab da
man ja keine technik benutzt und danach
stellte er ihnen noch mal für zwölf
stunden in den kühlschrank und dann ist
er wirklich schön kalt und kann sofort
verzehrt werden bei mir ist es jetzt so
dass jetzt wirklich schon stichfest
geworden und es macht tatsächlich keinen
unterschied ob mit oder ohne deckel
sitzen auf der falschen seite aber ihr
seht schon hier ist wirklich auch keine
flüssigkeit drauf ganz wenig nur weil
einfach das datum hat die ganze
feuchtigkeit rauszieht und wie gesagt
sechs stunden nach jetzt ungefähr drin
er ist schon schön stichfest aber
natürlich noch warm das heißt ich las
denn jetzt kurz abkühlen
dann kommt er im kühlschrank und sobald
dann kalt ist können wir in 14
und im prinzip könnt ihr euch aus diesem
joghurt jetzt immer wieder joghurt
züchten das heißt am besten hebt ihr ein
schälchen immer für die weiter züchtung
auf und den rest können ihr vernaschen
unsere kinder die essen joghurt also
meine mama die macht immer ein kilo
joghurt pro woche und eine kritische und
auch immer gut weg weil die kinder
einfach viel essen und wir machen da zum
beispiel auch gerne mal frische früchte
reihen oder essen joghurt müsli wir
essen joghurt aber auch gerne zu vielen
hauptspeisen ich kenne meine videos und
wisst wie sehr und wie viel gold wie
verzerrt
von daher ist es jetzt echt ein ganz
cooles video geworden glaub ich falls
ihr noch fragen habt schreibt sie gerne
in die kommentare falls ihr noch tipps
und tricks habt auch gerne natürlich und
dann hoffe ich dass euch das video
gefallen hat und ja dann sehen wir uns
wieder beim nächsten mal
ich würde ihnen jetzt am liebsten schon
an löffeln aber es hat noch warm aber
schon gut stichfest ich schlafe liegen
dann für euch an männer schön kalt ist
okay jetzt ist der joghurt richtig schön
fest und kalt und wir probieren ihn und
ich nehme mir dazu denn j&j kommen bitte
komm in die küche und probierten joghurt
mit mir
ich habe hier sogar ein rosa häufig für
dich aber dann auch schon ein goldener
gleich golden sie sind okay ich bin
gespannt
aber was ist liebe ich komme morgen
hatte eine liste heute morgen
angestochen nicht bei dir ist auch nicht
weil bei dir der deckel drauf war und
weil man mich okay indes ende bis dann
der haut ja okay da kann man sich selber
aussuchen ob man die haut mark oder ob
ja so direkt inkl
ich glaube ich bin so besser persönlich
ja ich bin mit haut
richtig schön mit so richtig merken das
gar nicht wie joghurt so sauber ist ja
so auf den einkauf so martin
und wenn er meldete stand ich auf zucker
drin genau im durchschnitt hier nicht
nur schön leicht leicht und trotzdem
stichfest bei der stadt bisschen weicher
und ich das liegt auch daran dass bei
dem nämlich der deckel drauf war und
dann die feuchtigkeit eben nicht
entzogen wird der automaten und hierbei
den erstellten da wird die feuchtigkeit
entzogen weil es ohne deckel war also
könnte wirklich dann selber aussuchen
wenn er mit dem der automaten arbeitet
wenn ihr komplett ohne arbeitet sowieso
immer mit deckel arbeiten damit eben
auch nichts drankommt
also viel spaß und nachmachen eures
eigenen joghurts ist ein richtiger
deutscher sein mit eurem reichen york es
passt ich mache euch dann sagt einfach
so wer passt ja und die mädels die essen
den übrigens ganz gern entweder mit
abwärme lade oder etwas zerdrückten
erdbeeren also kann man sich ja selber
fruchtjoghurt machen so eigenen kleinen
frucht werk
[Musik]